القضية الإستراتيجية الكبرى هي أن أوكرانيا
تريد العضوية في حلف شمال الأطلسي
إذا حصلت على
العضوية في حلف شمال الأطلسي. لا أعتقد أنها مستعدة لعضوية حلف شمال الأطلسي
ولكن هذه هي الصفقة التي
قضيتها،
كما تعلمون، وقتًا طويلاً في محاولة
الحفاظ على تماسك الناتو لأنني أؤمن
ببوتين.  لقد كان لديه هدف ساحق
منذ أن أطلق 185 ألف جندي
في أوكرانيا وكان ذلك هو كسر الناتو،
كان واثقًا من وجهة نظري والعديد من
مجتمع الاستخبارات، كان واثقًا من
قدرته على كسر الناتو،
إنه حلف شمال الأطلسي المقدس معًا أمر
بالغ الأهمية حقًا.
لا أعتقد أن هناك إجماعاً في حلف شمال الأطلسي
حول ما إذا كان سيتم ضم أوكرانيا
إلى
أسرة الناتو أم لا، الآن في هذه اللحظة في
خضم الحرب.